happy birthday special
this is the worst birthday podcast I'm
Michael Kosta thanks for being here
thanks for listening it's Thursday and
we upload a new episode every Thursday a
new worst birthday why Thursday Michael
well because people are getting ready
for the weekend
people have big birthday plans on the
weekend so I think Thursdays gives you
enough time to download and then listen
to maybe digest Friday and maybe maybe
it helps you with your birthday plans
maybe it helps make them bigger see the
disappointment is greater maybe it maybe
it helps you tame them down so you're
not as bummed out I don't root for bad
birthday's that just happen
automatically sometimes so we have a
great show this week we've a great show
every week really appreciate when you
guys tweet to us using hashtag worst be
de pod it's a nice way to meet all of
you I really appreciate that you can
always tweet to me at Michael Kosta this
week's guest Steve Simone tweet to him
tweet to both of us tell Steve you
enjoyed listening to his story you enjoy
he's this guy is very unique he's very
funny he's got a great outlook on life
and he's just a positive do does a lot
of charity work he'd go to his Twitter
page it's just all these different
charities she's working for it it's real
it's not [ __ ] a lot of people do
this stuff to get attention or to work
up the ladder of entertainment with
Steve it's real he's genuinely helping
and wants to help I have some new dates
on my speaking of a genuine person who
wants to help not me
I'm genuine but live dates can be found
in Michael Kosta calm I just got booked
New Year's Eve ladies and gentlemen
we're already talking New Year's if you
talk about disappointments New Year's
Eve I'll be at the Arlington draft house
the weekend of New Year's Eve that's
Thursday Friday and Saturday I think New
Year's Eve is on a Saturday this year oh
[ __ ]
people are gonna be a mess I'm checking
that as we speak on Saturday is New
Year's Eve
[ __ ] lower your expectations already
everybody if you're in the Washington DC
area maybe you just do a casual dinner
at home and then come out to the
Arlington draft house and watch Michael
Kosta perform comedy first time I ever
played at the Arlington draft house
there's a marquee up and they play
movies after the comedy show sometimes
in jackass three had just come out so
the marquee said Michael Kosta jackass
three I know
take a picture of it Liz Lemon please
tweet to steve Simone at Steve Simone
tweet to me at Michael Kosta leave us a
rating and a review that's always
appreciated I hope you enjoyed this week
worst birthday podcast we're on the all
things comedy Network and thank you so
much for listening
enjoy Steve we'll see on the other end
happy worst birthday
my younger brother had a buddy in high
school that was deaf but he would always
call my younger brother through the
relay Center is that because it was
because he could like type it out yes
okay and then that way that kid would
get beer underage because no nobody
would say do you have your do you have
your ID yeah like he looked like he
would could be 21 but since he was deaf
he was like bro it's the golden ticket
yeah I get served everywhere
cuz then he would just say he'd make a
really extra uncomfortable for the
person where they'd be like just take it
this take you don't even have to pay for
it god bless you well that is you know
you hear
military personnel talk about you know I
was addicted to painkillers or whatever
I just kept getting free [ __ ] because I
go to the bar and I keep getting because
I was served you know and it's like yeah
oh you got a limp in your right leg cuz
you took a [ __ ] again because you
fought for our country our you need man
whatever you [ __ ] need yep and deaf
but I just thought this was a great scam
one of my friends bought Lakers tickets
was supposed to on Craigslist was
supposed to exchange face to face the
person calls and says [ __ ] I'm in
Orlando the flight is all screwed up you
could hear like boarding announcement
yeah you could hear an airport yeah
which obviously you can just probably
play Airport on YouTube and it would
show an egos eye but I did FedEx you the
tickets if you could just wire me the
money again if they say why the money
don't wire anyone money so he had a
tracking number and the FedEx the wire
goes through the FedEx arrives it's
empty calls the number of the numbers
toast and you know it was a it was a
good deal on tickets it wasn't like
crazy but it was just good enough where
you would say yes yeah and he probably
did it 50 Pizza 50 people significant
amount it's a good amount of money it's
good amount of money I'm here with Steve
Simone have you been have you been
rigged on the Craigslist or you've
gotten close or anything no are you a
skeptical person because you don't you
seem like an optimistic hey I'm very
optimistic and happy but there's not
much that I want know and uh one of the
most interesting things I read a book
years and years ago
by this world-class conman and he said
it's essentially what makes a comm work
as somebody's greed yeah that the
person's greed will convince them that
it's the right thing to do I like that
and David Taylor once said that you
can't con an honest person right so
there's nothing really I want yeah you
have what you need what you need yeah
and then if it's an offer that's too
good to be true yeah I think where they
normally screw it up is they make it
just a little too good yes I looked at
this apartment once in West Hollywood
and it was so sick yes and I reached out
and the guys like well I'm the owner but
I live in Greece blah blah blah and I
went it's like what and then I went and
looked at the apartment but it had a for
sale sign on it and I called the realtor
and she's like I'm the realtor it's for
sale no one is renting this apartment
it's a scam at you in but the guy was
just asking for a $500 deposit I was I
was ready to do it
Wow my own greed yeah you're the perfect
human of course just stuff where I'm
like I don't really what's your vice do
you have a vice do you drink uh every
once in a while not really do you smoke
or anything you eat I recently gave up
chewing tobacco old skull was a tough
one for me nicotine and I still there
are times where I'm like could I just go
this and I won't do it's just I'm trying
my best not to do it is it it was just
like the winter cut or whatever uh
wintergreen what does it meant man yes
good man where did you grow up I grew up
in suburban Philadelphia and then went
to college in Baltimore yeah that's
where I picked up that habit with I
always associate dip with baseball yeah
it was non-athlete I'm just hanging out
how does one learn to dip cuz for me it
was it was the athlete thing cuz it
doesn't screw with your lungs and you
could still get high right well I had a
buddy of mine that
he was a baseball player names like you
ever try this yeah yeah so that's yeah
why do they love dip so much
seems like bait a vital there's a lot of
different sports but did many athletes
though do it yeah like I remember once
watching it like a documentary on Larry
Bird yeah people varieties from Kentucky
oh this right or Indiana yeah what one
of them yeah yeah Kentucky French Lick
and Jackie yeah yeah so like when they
eat just opened up his refrigerator and
every had like 15 cans of Copenhagen and
he would pour bourbon into it that's
[ __ ] and I might still didn't come my
college yeah and then they would put him
in the freezer yes oh oh my god well he
was he was white trash for sure he was I
mean Larry Bird was white trash but all
you had to do was look at his mustache
but what everything about that guy's
fantastic - the hair yeah the bravado
the provide everything with it would it
was the Sixers fan growing up so I hated
him okay so what is happening now
because now you know they Vegas is like
the over-under to start the season is
like they're gonna win 17 games or
something I mean they're like one of the
worst franchises ever by design is it
yeah they did whatever like
unfortunately I'm just a casual sports
fans just play my life but I think the
way the NBA is designed you need like
essentially two Hall Famers on your
support
sure to make it happen sure and the only
way to really get those guys is through
the draft so you're really not gonna
accomplish anything by being mediocre
right you got a Louie half the tank it
sit to get number one draft pick yeah
and get the most amount of lottery picks
exactly and that's that was their
strategy and then this year they finally
paid off with Ben Simmons yeah yeah and
I'm will say we'll see
so do you rep Philly then always that's
that's your [ __ ] yep are you did you
know Eleanor Kerrigan I did not not
before I got to the Commodore you didn't
know cuz who else is Philly in LA oh
there's so many so many in comedy yeah
there's a lot in comedy like a ton Joe
DeRosa Joe DeRosa Metzker Kephart big
Jay Neal Brennan
kay Tina Fey Timbo Philly all Philly
Philly's quietly had this unbelievable
comedy Renaissance
that's so funny like I remember one of
the first open mics I ever did was I
remember big J closed it out yeah and
there was a kid from North Philly who
introduced himself to me as little keV
shut up yeah little keV and now it's
biggest comedian in the world I mean
number may be the most profitable movie
star yeah it's unbelievable is he funny
yeah he was funny and it's so nice yeah
he was so nice I remember him I only did
like two or three open mics yeah but I
remember him when he was like dude I'm a
North Philly legend I'm gonna get you
you gotta come with me they'll love you
he was like crazy bro he was like he's
like you gotta come hang with me am i
good and did you always tell kind of I
mean cuz now in correct me if I'm wrong
yeah we used to work together a lot and
then now and then you got famous that is
yeah it's so famous but but no I just we
were put together a lot on the yeah and
I would love hearing your childhood
stories and and are you are you still is
it is that the world you were always in
um you know I think comedy always it's
always you we got to keep it evolve for
sure for me I I started to filter my
comedy through like I first you just try
to be funny
sure right and then I was always like
what's the most honest thing what's the
most honest thing my comedies from get
really dark yeah and then I was like
this is dark it's something that people
don't want to hear but right but then I
was like keep what is the most honest -
keep digging look deeper yeah and then I
started to tap into all this positivity
yeah and that's what I wanted to share
and it's almost like I'm at a point now
where last night I did a show where it
was almost like motivational speech
really like because I was like the world
so bad right now that this turn off your
TV I know this way yet you wanna I go
don't watch anymore news
yeah and just love the person in front
of you you know we will change the world
that's true I was like just be as kind
and as loving to the person in front of
you right now it's true
that's it and I started to talk about
that and gratitude and how everything
we've been taught to believe what we
want is an illusion it's not about money
and sure it's not about how we define
successes bananas
sure it's like you wake up she's
grateful in this country oh we're set
yeah we hit the lotto just by being born
America wrecked correct I mean the
homeless people in America are fat all
right I tell you about head shots yes
seriously I mean uh well one of the
jokes you do and I don't I hate saying
jokes because it's it's the story but as
is being a kid and having a sleepover
yeah and I put that on the CD it's so
funny and it's it's like it's optimistic
yeah it's it's and I remember watching
you perform it at the Comedy Store this
like dark place yeah you know I mean
really if you hang out in the back door
or the Comedy Store like you know you
can leave and like we want to just walk
into sunset and it is a dark raw place
and to hear you tell a story that's like
using these kids voices and that's this
kid in the whole audience who's been
hearing vicious vicious yeah some funny
some unfunny but vicious dark brutally
honest comedy and then to see them laugh
at it's a long story you have about
being a kid and is it the first
sleepover or it's just a sleepover yeah
that was just us of how much fun they
want and every single person is relating
yeah every because every single person
has done that yeah and I think what it
comes down to is like just from a
comedic point of view it's like you have
that choice
yeah like I was talking about buddy of
mine last night and I was like if you
want to complain and say everything
sucks I'm like yeah I get that yeah yeah
you want to go but not everything I mean
I'm like there's still puppies and ice
cream yeah right so yeah let's focus on
that yeah yeah it doesn't mean the bad
stuffs not there I'm not one of those
like just think positive and it'll go
I'm like no no you're absolutely right
that does suck yeah but what can we can
control and what is what is there to
celebrate because the way I look at life
is it flies by man yeah if it's gone in
the blink of an eye and it serves
nothing by being miserable no and when I
was in my early 20s I thought and meant
I understood more right right oh wait I
was an idiot yeah
you're growing yes there's growth and
comedic Lee you have to make a choice I
mean you can't bat and maybe you could
go back and forth but that would be
tougher hey here's a B+ joke here's a
[ __ ] it's funny that matter joke it'd
be tough what I would like to do is I
want to do a show up in the belly room
yeah and I just want to call it it's not
my voice right and to give comedians
immunity that'd be fun it was like
wouldn't it be great to hear somebody
that's a great joke teller tell a long
story sure or have somebody that's super
like if we got Louie up there and he was
like here's my favorite thing in the
world about birth instead of death great
to be funny
yeah that would be funny it's a good
idea sometimes you do get limited by
that comedic persona yeah but I try to
keep everything as open as honest as
possible yeah because I think like once
you break through that misery it's it
all starts to get beautiful yeah
well it's like I don't want to speak at
a tourney er because I'm certainly not a
Jewish person but it's like you know
people in the concentration camps would
find they would like a small was one of
my favorite today that's a great movie
it shows here he is like in this
miserable terrible dark place and he's
dancing for this kid yeah you know it's
yeah it's a it's a great it's a great
movie um when's your birthday June 28th
June 28th I kind of just had it yeah I
share it with Gilda Radner or Mel Brooks
oh wow that's a really good comedy birth
that's you want to talk about you know
looking at a positive side Gilda Gilda
Radner she has all these Gilda's clubs
yeah I want to do a show for them yeah I
mean it's like she she you know her
legacy lives on through her comedy but
absolutely even more importantly in its
bigger what's begotten what's gotten
bigger is that these clubs are they help
people that have cancer and their family
that's awesome yeah it's have you done
laughs fest in Grand Rapids now yeah
because that's that's the big one and
that's all Gilda so that's a really I
toured the the place there and it's like
yeah it's just Here I am bitching about
something on social media or I'm mad
about this or the hotel isn't what I
want he walked through the door there
and you're like shut the [ __ ] up Michael
yeah I was like these are real issues
real issues yeah I spent a lot of time
at a Children's Hospital and other
it's awesome still yeah how do you have
any blood drive coming up yeah yeah took
Friday and Saturday I think I'm oh I'm
pretty common yeah whatever man dude I
would love to do that yeah I would
please I would love to because they need
blood and that's one of those things or
it's so easy for people to get involved
but and all honestly like maybe
cynically or I never thought a blood
drive was that big a deal I'm like stuff
sorority girls do to feel like I didn't
it was that necessary yeah but then when
I got to literally see the difference it
made like there was a little guy I used
to go visit in the bone marrow
transplant unit and the day before he
needed a transfusion it was like a toy
that didn't have batteries right and
then the next day after that the kids
flight he's a kid again yeah is your you
[ __ ] blood yes you're keeping not
only you literally keeping these kids
alive but you're drastically improving
their quality of life and what I think I
don't want to get up on a soapbox but
people need to hear this yeah live in a
city Los Angeles second biggest city in
the country yeah they don't have enough
donors yeah that's for the kids at
Children's Hospital oh that's insane
well I was talking to somebody I go man
I want to do charitable work and I'm so
intimidated I have no idea where to
start cut this is it well this was up
with somebody called like I just started
to do stuff on my own I don't I went
down there for a blood drive sure and
what you said when you you just show up
at Gilda's house and go oh wait a sec
all of a sudden it's just like take just
take a break bro yes this is real yeah
it's real your life is a little video
Fantasy game this is the real sense you
could it and to me that's what what God
is is is seeing somebody that needs help
and having this feeling that you want to
help sure and I remember just getting
off the elevators at Children's Hospital
for the first time I'm like oh this is
whatever I whatever I can do to help
yeah and it just started to snowball
sure and then I met this guy named John
McNichol who started a company called
regular hero John's a the big listener I
think's John
right he's our hero yeah it's just like
you don't need it he was like just make
the world better one at a time one
person at a time I like that so he does
all kinds of cool stuff and I partnered
up with him and I do some stuff down the
Children's Hospital but he works with
the homeless he works sure that's with
PTSD he works with at-risk kids he works
with countries where they need drinking
water
yeah like the most basic physics we have
too much sitting in front of us you ever
I always want to do stuff for prisoners
me too isn't that it's always I always
feel like you know kids are it's
terrible when some bad happens to them
yes
that's it's like the worst now prisoners
they kind of already [ __ ] up probably
you're kind of like I think a lot of
society's like yeah you're kind of
getting what you deserve but it's also
like we imprison so many people oh it's
really have no rights there it's
absolutely I mean here's the thing even
if they deserve it
we're all human Oh Mike we all mess up
in like May based on my socio-economic
class I'm I don't get in trouble and
based off of yours you know you have
your cell and so I always want to do a
comedy show in jail so that's what I'm
kind of thinking about right now
you know you have to look up homeboy
industries do you know anything about
them no oh look there's this book called
tattoos on the heart okay stories of
compound less compassion or something
okay
and there's a there's a [ __ ] like
this some priest named father Gregory
Boyle that started this nonprofit okay
Boyle Heights which is like one of the
roughest neighborhoods in the world are
you here Boyle Heights I know what's up
yeah and it's all their slogan is
nothing stops a bullet nothing stops a
bullet like a job and then there's jobs
not jails and they rehab people coming
out of the prison system give them job
skills which is what the prisons are
supposed to do but they don't
rehabilitate they disappoint us you're
just a big business um I always thinking
I was thinking about that like man do I
get in trouble when I'm not working just
go to if there's a placed to go do
something even if it's just go to
Starbucks for two hours I just am
already better than absolute ice or you
know whatever you you can always find a
bar that's open or it's like you always
get in some shoes it's not working
absolutely
like about the podcast it's like it
gives us something to do sometimes when
it's the bet and what I have is this
it's getting to hang out with a buddy
that you wouldn't be at I'm like the
greatest I gotta go do this thing yeah
June 28th yeah okay what were what we're
birthdays like for you growing up that's
that's a summer birthday time yep good
time first off I was always a little bit
jealous of the kids missed birthdays
were during the school year because they
got to bring in the cupcakes well that's
what I always wanted the attention right
after handing out cupcakes on my
birthday right and they would also get
to hand out cupcakes to the hot chick
teacher and I remember one buddy in like
fourth grade Robbie katoya he was like
he was like you want to forget that
there was like miss miss martian or
something like yeah yeah and we got to
give her a cupcake she was hot yeah
isn't that funny and she's probably you
know at the time she was probably 27
yeah you know and it's like now we're
older than her I like the teacher that I
thought was so hot like I'm probably 12
years old I had a I had a birthday
during the school year and I always your
birthday's September 27th September
right at the beginning of the school
yeah though he's an attention you're a
cool kid at school but I was you know I
would throw parties and there would be a
lot of other prefer small September's
the most common good month for birthday
huh it's nine nine months back is New
Year's Eve and Christmas that's what
gotcha
we're just we're just basically rats we
all have sex at the same time but but I
want you to look I want you to be upon
to be positive with Steve Simone here I
always liked the summer birthdays
because you could throw it you could do
a thing and all the kids were around you
know if like for me it was like I need
to be on a weekend
yeah there's conflicts summer everyone's
out of school but that when you're a
real little kid when you're out of
school if you don't live in your
neighbor sure it's Bobble yeah so like
when I was a little guy had my school
friends in my neighborhood friends and I
was fortunate yeah that's some there was
some overlap there good but my younger
brother didn't have I didn't have I just
had his neighborhood clique in a school
clique and they're much different yeah
but here's okay yeah great things about
summer birthdays drop some he drops me
the best thing about having us
birthday was when you're a little kid
you don't have any money yeah so I had
two major events that I could it was a
stuff but it I could grab things I
needed it was Christmas or my birthday
right and I always felt bad for kids
whose birthdays were right near
Christmas for sure you've got almost six
months almost exactly exactly it was the
perfect perfect perfect so what would
you what would you ask for as a kid toys
yeah you know toys and cool stuff yeah
and the thing that made my birthday
magical when I was a little kid was my
younger brother and I are Irish twins
okay we are 51 weeks apart okay so his
birthday is June 24th what's an Irish
twig if someone told this to me
yesterday and I felt like I felt like it
was it is it super close to each other
it's kids that are not fraternal or
paternal drains that are born within 50
52 weeks so mom and dad had they got
this and they got busy yeah that's great
a lot of love in that family
mmm yeah like that okay yeah so it was a
big deal like Marky's birthday was on
the 21st mark yeah and then we were the
same age for a week it was a glorious
week brother week wow that's cool and
then my birthday was the 28th and I know
this sounds crazy but this is how I
viewed the world as a six year old yeah
I was like there's Marky's birthday yeah
then there's my birthday yeah and then I
honestly thought the fourth of July was
when the entire country celebrated both
of our birthdays that's very funny so I
was just in continuation on like party
party party and then we do accommodation
and there enough date you know it's
seven days from his birthday and it's a
brown 7 days July 4 yeah perfect how old
were you when you realize that wasn't
the case
um well I know you wanted to talk about
my stinkiest birthday yeah sure
stinkiest and it was like it was my
eighth birthday what are your about it
alright man so like I ate the birthday
this is this fascinates me that people
[ __ ] remember this yes amazing it's
also good we remember you know what we
care about but remember what we have
emotions attached to yeah and so
obviously this affected you
because you remember it yeah and I'm a
little autistic or something I remember
everything I don't think that the
characters have autism
yeah I'm just inventing things
it's your eighth birthday yeah and let
me just first go on record frame it look
I don't really celebrate my birthday
like I'm not one of those grown-ups sure
like I kind of feel bad sure for adults
that truck in my opinion are probably
trying to compensate for what they
didn't get okay
all right all right when I see an adult
like that takes Halloween too seriously
they're like yeah you need a hug when
Will Hunting yeah there's something sad
go something something is up
bro I picked out my costume I'm like
you're 36 years old I agree like hand
I'll candy the little kids make it about
them well like a lot of women put on the
super sexy thing and it's like awesome I
mean it's beautiful fun to look at but
it's like you're really trying to cover
something up something's up yeah yeah I
always like the girl that goes is like
[ __ ] like Bigfoot not sexy it's a
great little subplot and we love that
yeah yeah cuz look man I killed
Halloween as a kid I'm like and that was
it was for being a kid Yeah right
it's like I feel the same way about my
birthday's I'm a man I don't care sure
it's like yeah whatever do and what I'm
gonna rupture you laugh but what did
what did you do this last birthday it
was a few weeks ago I ordered Chinese
food and I sat by myself and watching
that floor and your and enjoyed a night
of quiet that's nice that's exactly what
did you do comedy that night no no I was
just like I'm good dude that's a gift
it's a gift or not I mean it's a gift
that we're lucky that we get to do
comedy but every once in a while stop
doing it and then [ __ ] have some
Chinese food
you have to yeah you got to you got to
live because I think it's comics we're
get so focused on our careers that we
rob ourselves for the joy of living well
that's what Ryan and stout and I were
just talking about rallies canceled a
gig and you cancelled this podcast to go
to New York with a girl awesome and it
was last-minute and I go that's exactly
what you're supposed to that you're
supposed to live man I'm gonna live and
then write jokes about what happens yeah
exactly in a long-term it's a better
strategy other strategy all right so
you're eight I'm eight years old okay
you're turning eight I'm turning eight
so I'm actually a 7 year old kid okay
and I remember this okay yeah the family
vacation yeah we were going to go to
Virginia Beach and it was a big one
because my mom and pop up were coming
with us okay and my dad my grandpa so
there was limited amount of dates okay
so the week vacation that lined up best
for everybody would be we would have
Marquis but we'd have my younger
brother's birthday thrown the whole
party he'd have his magical day then
we'd go to the beach and then we would
come back home on my birthday okay okay
I don't think that's ideal well here's
the thing yeah when I was a little guy
birthdays they were legitimately magical
yeah and you do as a child you don't
realize that adults make out like I have
a whole bit now about seeing my parents
as humans right and loving them more
because of that right like I didn't
appreciate my mother sure as a kid she
just like I thought she was like I'm
like non-human like it sure a creature
that just took care of me and my
brothers Erik Griffin said on his
podcast as a kid you want the government
to pay for everything and the government
is your parents you just think it just
happens yeah you don't have anything you
don't have any yeah you didn't see your
mom as a real yeah I think thought it
was like Santa Claus Easter Bunny yeah
give me a hug mom make me a sandwich
yeah you know I mean exactly like I'm
and I thought she was magic like I just
legitimately thought she was like this
magical yeah like I don't know I like I
have a joke about watching her make a
sandwich I'm like I don't know how she
does my little brother's like I know it
starts off as bread yes like you know
what I mean because I could see all the
ingredients I'm like how do you put them
together then you still can't do it as
well as you know so I remember they
explained it to me they were like
sweetie if this is the way it is it's
gonna affect your birthday yeah and I'm
like uh but Beach yeah let's go to the
beach bro yeah yeah let's do it yeah
they're like yeah and I was like and
then we come back and it's my birthday
but I think they were trying to explain
that it wouldn't yeah this is what I
thought okay when I was say turned seven
I woke up and it was my day yeah it was
like Christmas yeah
but just for me yeah and we would wake
up and there would be gifts wrapped and
balloons hanging like you know how like
Santa Claus would come in the night no
my birthday presents would come in them
I would wake up and would be my birthday
there would be streamers and balloons
and awesomeness so and this is your mom
and your dad yeah doing this doing it
absolutely that's awesome so cool yeah
and then it was just waiting for my
party that night we did all my parties
at my house and it was great sweet like
I really think like when I was 4 years
old
I essentially was famous right like the
whole world lined up to kiss my ass
right they all wanted a picture with me
yeah I'd scribble something on a piece
of paper they'd hang it up they loved it
everywhere I went people would tell me
how cute I was yeah I'm like yeah it
kind of is being famous that's it yeah
it is yeah that's why the destruction of
innocence is so tough but it's like I
had this was I had the world in my hand
yes I was five or four right right yeah
like I peaked at four yeah garden kicked
my ass and I'm still recovering oh so we
go to the beach and now I'm thinking I'm
like well the birthday magics just gonna
happen cuz it's my birthday and how
could how could June 28th exist without
birthday magic sure and on the positive
I remember my grandmother taking me
shopping me pick out some gifts at like
souvenir stands and I think it's in
storage somewhere but I had one of those
sweet coconuts that they may look like a
pirate awesome like that's as good as it
gets
it's a coconut and a pirate island bro I
love that I asked Steve who's maybe the
most positive optimistic person about
something that's bad the worst birthday
this is great this is a fun it's it's
fun watching your brain like piece this
together yeah it's awesome
okay cuz ultimately it's all amazing
yeah but so that I'm like yeah this is
great I'm gonna get my birthday gifts
before my birthday coconut then like we
wake up in a hotel room and I'm like
where's the birthday magic and I think
there might have been something there
I'm sure mom did something but then
pretty much the whole days driving back
yeah
and how far is that to Philly well I
think we were in Virginia Beach so it
was probably a good five six hours and
and probably the same way my family I
mean
you drove on vacation yeah drama they're
flying with exactly it was you drove on
a vacation yeah gas was 14 cents a
gallon
dude it was the bass yeah it was it was
fun looking for fireworks and like all
kinds of cool souvenirs you dad
fireworks over fireworks fireworks yeah
my dad was always like kids stay free
you know under 12 like kids you have to
hide underneath the seats like we all be
sleeping in one hotel I mean now it was
great yeah now I'd be miserable but
that's great it's sad the thing I want
parents who keep Mike I have a friend of
mine who's a comic who's on a ridiculous
family vacation one of those this week
and he was like how am I not gonna lose
my mind like focus on the kids yeah cuz
they're my knees for memories forever we
went to gallon burg Tennessee and my
brother bought a knife a small knife and
we still joke about like he wasn't
allowed to buy the night but he bought
it anyways that we were in the backseat
showing the knife and it was just like
yeah my dad was probably thinking work
or we got to get home or you know this
this and this and we're going like we
got this nut it was so sweet
amazing right I remember getting a
switchblade comb when I was like all my
life no giant novelty cigars a
switchblade comike all that junk you can
buy a tourist traps sofa I'm all for so
you're so you're awake you're in the car
yeah for your birthday yeah and I'm like
and in my brain I think this one is
dawned on everybody that I'm I expected
birthday magic yeah and I've always been
kind of very optimistic kind of Mike Lee
well one up we get home it'll be my
Bismarck like that he's he is optimistic
but he's he's much smarter than I am
where does this optimism come from what
parent me neither
so maybe it's maybe it's a was probably
born I mean it's obvious yeah survival
mechanism yeah yeah okay got it
okay cuz being a middle child and crazy
loud house so your
Marx younger than you yeah Chris is the
oldest Chris and Chris is on this trip
as well yep okay good course here okay
when's calling the shots when's Chris's
birthday August 14
Wow okay all summer birthday
yep okay hey Chris hey Don hey Mark so
you get home and there's not birth day
magic yeah so then I'm assuming like oh
god soon as we get home though there
will be balloons and streamers and then
it sort of dawns on me like wait yeah
there's no birthday magic because all
the people that make it happen we're in
the car yeah yeah and I'm like and I
started to go wait that maybe there's
more to all of this yeah all right yeah
I start like June 28th goes on whether
it's my birthday or not and there's like
serious life lessons started early on it
sure and then this is what made it
stinky though stinkier it wasn't like
they open up the closet who uses
stinkier as a word like you couldn't
have bought my gifts in advance and just
had them wrapped in the closet right
that couldn't have happened right so
this is what you're thinking now yeah
like now I got to go with you guys as
you could do my birthday shopping right
then that's what we did and then my
brothers would have to like distract me
when I was in the store so you went you
you got home and you went and did that
yeah that's hilarious
yeah and I do remember this my mom tried
to cover up the gifts in the cart or
whatever at the store called clover
I heard from vivica over yeah and then
uh cuz they had a pretty good toy
section yeah and I do remember one of
the gifts I got that birthday so it
wasn't all lost okay was I do remember
getting Connect four you know cuz I like
the chick on the commercial which was
like pretty sneaky sis and then I will
have to find that YouTube pretty sneaky
sis oh it's one of the best 80s cartoon
commercials ever so I find this
interesting that you were you were
finding out it was a stinky birthday and
then the family then took you shopping
yeah I mean did Steve call some of the
shot did the kids call the shots like
that if I said this is a stinky birthday
in my house they'd go sorry it's stinky
good night no because I think it was
this there was always the understanding
that on your birthday you're gonna get
gifts got it and up into that point I
didn't get them yet God does that make
sense yep I got it and it would be super
tough for the parents to plan all this
because you're planning a vacation plus
there's in walls involved Grandma and
Grandpa
can't what ya getting the whole huh cuz
like we were raised like monkeys yeah
three little boys under the age of ten
its chaos your mom it was your poor mom
I don't know how she yeah that's crazy
I'm where my dad would like drive home
and stay in his car for as long as
possible
we're here to come in the house I think
that's a Judd Apatow scene in some some
movie where the the man of the house is
just in his car like fine fine with it
and my dad would read in the driveway in
the driveway yeah he had the air
conditioner on a her she's big block a
sports talk radio and well yeah we'd
like that dad wait wait is that Dad and
we're looking at there's dad there's
that you just wave from the car okay
buddies five more minutes and then we'd
get back into doing what we were doing
them in twenty minutes and if not were
like did dad ever come in I don't know
did that come in no we still outside
attack attack and then we jump on his
car like monkeys in a drive-thru Safari
I've even done it I've even done at my
apartment where I've just stayed in my
car and not gone in there's nobody in
the apartment but I just like once you
walk in the door like kind of real life
happens
interesting you got like dishes to do or
you got like an email it was just night
it's just like it's the solace of your
car and I'm sure your death was
appreciating that absolutely what was
his work what did he do he was a math
teacher okay professor he must have been
good with kids I would think yeah he was
kind in a lot of ways like a big kid
himself
okay got it like he would get into it
yeah do you want kids yeah yeah okay
yeah for sure but now I'm getting so old
where I'm like maybe it won't happen
that's so tough like to find a woman
that what number one wants that yeah
and then number two in LA it's tougher
yeah many the girls I mean are more like
Janice where else he from good fellows
then he's somebody that would be that
mom yeah yeah you may need just to move
to Michigan or but you know what dude or
everybody says that and is that not true
I travel a lot I guess society's just
changed to the point where yeah I don't
know like the last girl I dated she
would have been a great mom she
definitely wanted that
and that's like that that was like kind
of like the thing that was keeping us
together yeah
like hey we want the same stuff out of
laughs yeah but she wasn't like you have
to have a charlie nice you don't have to
be nice but but it's like there's gonna
be so much like when that kid shows up
yeah it's just like let's keep it like
that's where all your energy and tension
has to go
it's and that's tough for people yeah it
is I also think I think and you don't
know this till it happens unfortunately
but I think if someone is a little
selfish in their life or self-absorbed
and the kid happens I think some of that
naturally does change
yes Janette just chemically yes I think
it's just like because I'm a you know I
think about you know this is a
self-absorbed business yeah and it's
like I got a dog and all of and that's
nothing even not even close 1% of a kid
probably and all of a sudden you do have
to think about something else other than
yourself 24 hours a day yeah it change
it just has to JJ I honestly think yeah
women get magical powers when they're
because it is well they have magical
powers in the first place they did like
it Amelia don't stop and think about it
they say you didn't exist I didn't exist
you didn't exist so Aaron actually has
existed he's a goat no but you're right
it the whole thing is mad magic yeah
it's insane yeah it's great and they're
and they do it yeah we don't do it a
hundred percent yeah and then also
they're like they pick us man totally
like how come you're not married because
nobody picked me yeah that's Squatch
like we we all think we're in charge nut
dude yes they pick us watch any planet
Earth yet watch any mating sequence the
the you know birds the male in a lot of
species like cleans an area on the
forest floor literally cleans their face
does it dance for the woman as a woman
looks at and then goes goes away
picks another bird it is it is men
constantly showing off for their
selection yeah it's all that and more
than not it does not happen no I don't
know how we got talking about this but
it's hilarious not awesome so eighth
birthday you get Connect four and then
come home and it's probably bedtime
isn't it you're eight I can't believe
you remember some of this stuff
I remember this what I think happened
early road on the road early yeah my dad
was a big believer in that and there's
also something kind of magical about
that like it adds to it I'm a big
believer in like manipulating time
things seem cooler okay like when you
wake up before the Sun's up and then
like you like sleep in the car and
you're a good so let's say we got home
around noon or 1:00 in the afternoon
unpack our stuff were back from the
store by 4:00 and then I have my
birthday dinner again it's amazing
but I don't remember I don't remember I
don't think I had a party that night
yeah you know someone always always yeah
I didn't not have a birthday cake until
I like move to LA Wow
which was how long you been in LA 16
years Wow so I was a full-blown grown-up
was that tough when you first moved here
too because yet so I think moving to LA
everything everything about it was tough
for me that's super tough yeah I
remember the first time being sick
without your parents without how he was
without my mom I mean my dad was just
working but it was like to be sick it's
like having a birthday without the cake
it's like oh this this is this is harder
now yeah you're in sure I'm in charge of
myself yeah everything's harder yeah and
then LA like that's why I have like a
certain whenever I see a kid show up at
the Comedy Store like I'm like whatever
I can do the help this person yeah like
a new guy you mean yeah cuz this this
city is uh it's it's tough where did you
live when you first moved here when I
first moved here there was a kid that
graduated with my younger brother okay
who lived in Santa Monica okay and there
was a one of his roommates was another
girl that graduated with my younger
brother
so I crashed on their couch for like ten
days found moved into an apartment with
two roommates like their third roommate
was moving out right and these guys at a
pizza place were like I we have a spot
for you so I'm like awesome
yeah I lived in Santa Monica and you
were doing comedy already not really
okay okay and and and how did you get
into the comedy
store scene um while it's interesting
because I had one back in 2000 I won
this contest it was sponsored it was
like laughs your bass off was sponsored
by bass ow
okay and uh in Philly Philly okay and
then it was the finals were hosted by
Pauly Shore oh my god and he was like
dude we thought yeah yeah but he was
like by this point I'd been the LA on a
vacation yeah and quit my job like I
came back to Philly I'm like so long
suckers I'm not doing this [ __ ] and then
I didn't have enough money to move to LA
so I entered this contest Pauly was like
a man you're really funny you should be
at the Comedy Store how long you been
doing this I'm like not really I don't
know what I'm doing Wow and he was like
dude you got something so that's cool
that's cool yeah he was probably wasn't
a busy a movie star yet at that point he
was definitely he'd already made his
movies he already had a sit-down but he
was a known yeah yeah he was a you know
celebrity yeah yeah and I moved to LA
his I had kept a piece of paper that his
road manager wrote his cell phone down
and that guy was home I'm a penis guy
Dean that ran the comedy I met I'm a
Dean when I first moved out here yeah
hey that was his road manager yes oh my
god doesn't Dean like he told me he was
selling tea in Hawaii and everyone's
like he did he says he grows weed or
something but I remember signing up for
a couple open mikes and then Dean got me
a job as a PA on paulie's movie okay and
I remember one it was like one of the
hardest days I it was I didn't get home
until like 3:30 4 o'clock in the morning
right
and I remember it was like 2:00 in the
morning when I was literally a guy
carrying couches like that by myself
down steps and Pauly's like eating
granola is yeah bro you're working hard
huh huh but he was cool enough to call
me that night when I got home and he was
like I appreciate how hard you worked
I'm gonna make sure you get in at the
Comedy Store cuz I I wanted to be a door
guy I want to go and he got me a job
answering phones there in January of
2001 which was great because it meant I
no longer had to get
picked out of a bucket for the open mind
yeah alright you got the guaranteed
stage time guaranteed stage time because
the open mic then you'd have to sign up
on Saturday night Oh
and that meant paying for parking on the
Sunset Strip right so it was like 20
bucks and then they would chance
and then they would draw a Sunday yeah
for the following week that's rude so it
was like a three-car trip
yeah that started and they used to do
well now you sign up Sunday night and
they pick it an hour later yeah okay
yeah yeah oh man that's it's a trip if
you haven't been to the Comedy Store you
know obviously I recommend all nights
but the Sunday night open mic you know
you drive by it's 6-7 p.m. and you just
see a line of comics yeah it's Monday
nights now money that's yeah yes crazy
but Steve Simone very quickly what is a
great birthday you've had I bet you've
had a [ __ ] Wow so many great birth
what's one that pops out as soon as I
said that oh well I remember the one
gift that pops out okay
I remember my fifth birthday some four
years old yeah and like this is like
right in the peak
I also remember I guess it must have
been my third birthday okay because that
was the bicentennial year and our memory
is nuts
it's crazy it's nuts well I remember
like I was in a like a little red white
and blue jumper on my birthday and then
that's where the whole thought process
was like wait it was marques birthday
then it was my birthday
now it's fireworks so I'm like okay this
this is cool
it's Markie and Steve's birthday
celebration the rest of the countries
caught up yeah this great but for my
fifth birthday yeah I remember telling
everybody how I wanted this Godzilla
yeah and I remember my grandfather's
like huh what's God's dama I'm like pop
you don't understand was awesome yeah
your math teacher go together
so notice my grandfather oh sorry Graham
yeah so I remember he loaded me in the
car and took me to kiddie City so I
could pick it out myself
that's sick and I was the greatest was
this giant Shogun warrior Godzilla and
he pressed this thing the back and his
tongue shot out like fire great it's
good greatest gift ever
where is it now you think I think it's
my older brothers basement okay the
if not I would totally buy 100 or I
would want you to yeah
show it to me and take a picture of it
but it for that but that's okay dude is
a great YouTube commercial for it what's
it what's it called Godzilla Shogun
warrior Godzilla Shogun warrior we also
got the Kinect for I'm gonna I'm gonna
make sure your great little I got two
great
Steve Simone where can where can people
find out where can people buy your
albums where can people find out about
your live dates yeah go to awesome Steve
calm yes great way it's all on there I
do a podcast called good times I would
love to have you on it I'd love to do it
it's also here on me all things calm I
don't think I'm available unfortunately
sighs don't belong give me the judge
smells I would love to do that and where
do they get the onl things comedy yep
awesome Steve calm Twitter at Steve
Simone and all things comedy put out my
CD call to remember this okay great
so it's all there that's awesome I'm
sorry that your eighth birthday sucked
yeah but I got it was pretty good yeah
still being pretty good but I'm sorry
was your worst birthday thank you for
joining me on the podcast thank you for
letting me hang out at flew by you got
that Steve Simone ladies and gentlemen
it's great June 28th eighth birthday I
mean Steve it was a little bit of a
stretch asking him to do this podcast
because he's so positive he's so
optimistic sometimes you want to smack
him in the face cuz you're like you know
quit being such a [ __ ] like happy
person but he just is that way
he is that we is that way in real life
we got to make one correction Aaron
pointed out Thank You Aaron French Lick
is in Indiana
okay the hick from French Lick Steve had
said Kentucky I knew it was Indiana what
am I correct my guest no you just say
Kentucky and then and then you move on
from there I'm gonna reach out to him
about donating blood regular hero is
someone he foundation he mentioned as
well as homeboy industries I'll make
sure to tweet out I don't know if we can
even do this on all things comedy but to
connect for YouTube and the Godzilla
Shogun YouTube commercial do I have a
blog do you guys have a blog we'll
figure it out if you just check us out
go the all things comedy page go to
worst birthday calm we'll figure out a
way to put those YouTube's or just
YouTube it yourself you [ __ ] lazy
[ __ ] YouTube Google Shogun commercial
I'm excited or excuse me you YouTube
Godzilla Shogun that Steve Simone check
them out awesome Steve calm this is the
worst birthday podcast please if you
tweet to us tweet using the hashtag
worst bday pod you can always email me
questions concerns guests that you think
will be kick-ass it's Michael at Michael
Kosta calm we're on Soundcloud
we're on iTunes if you leave a rating
and a review it I'll suck your dick how
about that the today's day and age it
doesn't matter if you have a good
product it only matters if people say
it's good on the internet it's [ __ ]
but it is what it is
so leave a positive review I'd leave
leave a review
we prefer positive but the reviews are
they all add up so thank you very much
for doing that
every Thursday we have a new worst
birthday podcast go to Michael Kosta
calm for all of your live dates and I
love you guys hope you have a great
birthday thanks